hello and welcome to med simplified
scabies has been known to mankind for
more than 3000 years
scabies is an ancient worldwide disease
affecting all races and social classes
in every climate from arctic to
equatorial regions
scapes is caused by a mite which lays
eggs in the human skin these eggs then
hatch and grow into adult mites which
repeat this cycle
this means that the signs and symptoms
of the skin condition can last for
months or even years if not treated
properly
in this video we will take a brief look
on the organism that causes scabies its
signs and symptoms
and then we will talk about how to treat
scabies
so let's begin
scabies is a very common disease and
globally more than 200 million people
are affected every year with a
particularly high prevalence in poor
tropical regions
it is an important public health problem
worldwide and can occur at any age
affecting both males and females equally
now let's talk about the organism
responsible for scabies which is
basically a mite known as sarcoptes
scabie
humans discovered this mite in the 17th
century and scabies might has been
mentioned even in the old testaments of
bible and many books of shakespeare
you would be surprised to know that
human scabies was the first disease in
which the causative organism was
discovered by using a microscope
this mite is oval
pearl-like white organism with lots of
legs and special structures on their
legs known as suckers
at a time about 10 to 12 mites can
affect an individual the life cycle of
the mite is completed entirely on human
skin
and it starts when a pregnant mite
attaches on the skin
this female mite dugs up a tunnel like
structure on the human skin which is
known as a burrow
this burrow can be up to one centimeter
long and the mite lays her eggs along
the spuro
each mite can lay up to 50 eggs during
her life cycle
these eggs then hatch into larvae in
three to four days and escape the burrow
the larvae then transform into next
stage in their life cycle known as
nymphs
and in the next four to seven days these
nymphs mature into adult males and
females hence completing the cycle
the burrows of the mites are often
visible as very thin lines mostly less
than one centimeter in length
often scratching of these itchy burrows
results in bacterial infection of skin
so called secondary bacterial infection
the scabies might are capable of
surviving in the environment outside of
the human body for up to three days in
normal room conditions
schematic infestation can be classified
into classical scabies which is the most
common form
and animal transplanted scabies which is
acquired from animals like dogs horses
etc
and lastly we have crusted scabies or
norwegian scabies
here the host may be colonized with many
millions of mites
it is the most severe form of scabies
and happens in people with weak immune
system
such as those caused by
infections like hiv blood cancers or
chronic use of steroids or other drugs
that suppress the immune system
now we will discuss about the risk
factors for transmission of scabies
the risk factors for transmission
include poverty
overcrowding poor hygiene
poor nutritional status
homelessness
dementia and immunosuppression
you can get scabies by coming in
physical contact for a significant
amount of time with someone who has kps
or you can also get scabies by using the
same dolls beddings clothes or other
formites used by someone who has kps
how do you know if you have scabies so
let's talk about the signs and symptoms
of this disease
it can be asymptomatic for the first
couple of weeks but the hallmark of the
scabies is severe itching that usually
worsens at night and typically appears
four to six weeks after the initial
infestation
in addition to itching you can have skin
lesions in the form of tiny red bumps
that are usually present over the webs
or fingers
inner aspects of wrists underarms
umbilicus and perium lycal region
it can be anywhere on the body except on
an adult's face
but in infants and elderly all skin
surfaces are susceptible to infestation
the patients also gave a history of
similar complaints in family members and
closed contacts which is very common
now let's talk about how escapee is
diagnosed
diagnosis is mostly clinical and is
based upon typical signs and symptoms
that we have discussed previously in
this video
typical symptoms typical site of
involvement typical appearance of skin
lesions all of which we have already
discussed in the earlier half of this
video
also not to forgets history of similar
complaints in family members or closed
contacts is very common
the definitive diagnosis is made by
microscopic identification of scabies
mite eggs or fecal pellets also known as
scabula
now coming to the last part of this
video here we will discuss what are
different treatment options we have for
treating scabies
which can be basically divided into
topical drugs which are creams and
lotions applied over the skin and oral
medications
topical medications include soaps body
washes lotions creams and gels
we will look at them one by one
the list of topical agents used are
permethrin five percent crotomaton 10
lindane one percent or benzyl benzoic
lotion
per methane five percent cream or lotion
is the most commonly used first line
topical therapy for treating scabies
permethrin kills both the adult mite as
well as the eggs and is therefore highly
effective after a single application
however in practice the prescribed
regime often involves two applications
which is to be applied to the full body
from neck down and 8 to 14 hours of
contact period is required so we
generally tell our patients to apply it
in the night and wash it off in the
morning
benzyl benzoate has been used in 10 to
25 percent preparation in many countries
including europe and australia but its
use is limited by severe skin irritation
chrotomaton 10
has been favored in children due to its
low toxicity profile
however it has limited efficacy and
multiple applications are usually
required to achieve a satisfactory
response
so these were the topical drugs that are
applied over the skin for treating
scabies
now let's look at the oral drugs that
are used for treating scabies
the most common oral drug that is used
is ivermectin
ivormectin is prescribed as a single
dose of 12 milligram for adults and 6
milligram for children below 10 years of
age
often a second dose of iomectin is given
after 14 days
a second dose is required to kill all
the eggs of the mite which can hatch
after some time and can lead to a
relapse
moxitectin is a newer agent that is
being used to treat scabies
it has better retention in the skin and
a much longer half-life than ivermectin
meaning that a single dose may be enough
to eliminate the complete infestation
it also appears to prevent a
reinfestation for a longer period of
time compared with ivermectin
to relieve itching patients are also
given anti-itching medications like
citrus in liver citrazine and other
antihistaminic drugs
in my experience as a dermatology
resident two of the most commonly used
treatments for scabies are topical
permethrin five percent and oral
ivormectin
both has comparable efficacy and are
generally very well tolerated
now let's look at some of the lifestyle
modifications you should do to prevent
scabies and its relapse
you need to kill all mites that may be
present on your clothing dolls and
bedding by doing one of the following
wash them in hot water and dry them in a
hot dryer or keep them in direct
sunlight for at least two days
and the items you cannot wash
wrap them in a closed plastic bag and
keep them in sunlight for at least three
days so that all the mites die
always remember that a good personal
hygiene is the most important thing you
can do to prevent scabies and its
reinfection
i hope you liked the video if you found
this video helpful make sure to press
the like button below and subscribe to
our channel as we upload health and
fitness related videos every week you
can also consider to hit the bell icon
next to the subscribe button so you can
get notified when we release our new
videos
thank you so much for watching and see
you in the next one till then take care
bye